.
TUCKER THANK YOU.
AND GOOD POINT ON DENMARK AND
THE VACCINES.
WELCOME TO HANNITY, WE BEGIN
TONIGHT IN MARTHA'S VINEYARD
WHICH IS DESCENDING TONIGHT INTO
CHAOS.
FOR YEARS THE ULTRA LIBERAL
WEALTHY ENCLAVE FEATURED SIGNS
LIKE THIS ALL OVER THE TOWN
READING WE STAND WITH IMMIGRANTS
AND REFUGEES.
ALL ARE WELCOME HERE.
SO YESTERDAY FLORIDA GOVERNOR
RON DeSANTIS SENT 50 ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS ON CHARTER PLANES TO
MASSACHUSETTS SO THEY COULD TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE INCLUSIVE
ENVIRONMENT THAT THEY CLAIM IS
MARTHA'S VINEYARD AND WHAT THEY
HAVE TO OFFER.
BUT AS IT TURNS OUT, WELL, THE
ELITE RESIDENTS THERE ARE NOT
ACTUALLY ALL THAT INCLUSIVE.
THEY ARE NOT ALL THAT WELCOMING.
AND THEY DON'T REALLY STAND WITH
THE IMMIGRANTS AND REFUGEES AND
NOW THEY WANT THEM GONE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE DIFFICULT CHALLENGES ARE,
WE HAVE, AT SOME POINT IN TIME
THEY HAVE TO MOVE SOMEWHERE
ELSE.
SFLIET WE CANNOT -- WE DON'T
HAVE THE SERVICES TO TAKE CARE
OF 50 IMMIGRANTS, AND WE
CERTAINLY DON'T HAVE HOUSING.
WE'RE IN A HOUSING CRISIS AS WE
ARE ON THE ISLAND.
SO WE DON'T -- WE CAN'T HOUSE
EVERYONE HERE THAT LIVES HERE
AND WORKS HERE.
WE DON'T HAVE HOUSING FOR 50
MORE PEOPLE.
>> Sean: FOR YEARS I'VE ALWAYS
SAID LIBERALS ARE GENEROUS WITH
OTHER PEOPLE'S MONEY.
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE, THEY'RE
ALL, LET'S SEE, PRO IMMIGRANT IN
SANCTUARY CITIES BUT NOT THEIR
CITY.
THEY HAVE TO MOVE FROM HERE TO
SOMEWHERE ELSE.
THEY CAN'T BE HERE.
ONLY 50 PEOPLE.
REMEMBER, ARIZONA, TEXAS,
THEY'RE DEALING WITH MIS.
THEY DON'T HAVE SPACE FOR 50
MIGRANTS, NOT IN ANY OF THE
BEAUTIFUL HOMES IN EDGAR TOWN,
NOT IN ANY OF THE PALATIAL BEACH
FRONT ESTATES DOTING THE ISLAND,
NOT EVEN WHERE OBAMA HAS A SEVEN
BEDROOM EIGHT BATHROOM 7000
SQUARE FEET 30-ACRE VACATION
HOME PROBABLY SITTING EMPTY AS
WE SPEAK.
WHAT, NO GUESTS ALLOWED?
NO ILLEGAL -- WHY DON'T WE BUILD
ON 12 OF THE ACRES A TENT CITY
FOR ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS?
THEY HAVE 30 ACRES.
THAT'S A LOT OF ACREAGE.
KEEP IN MIND NEARLY 80% OF THE
ISLAND'S RESIDENTS ARE HARDCORE
DEMOCRATS WHO VOTED FOR OBAMA
AND BIDEN THEY SUPPORT OPEN
BORDERS AND SANCTUARY CITIES AND
STATES.
AND YET, JUST 50 MIGRANTS LATER
AND THE ENTIRE ISLAND HAS NOW
ENTERED INTO A FULL-BLOWN STATE
OF PANIC, RACISM, ACCORDING TO
THEIR DEFINITION, AND XENOPHOBIA
AND OF COURSE THEY'RE BLAMING
REPUBLICANS AND RON DeSANTIS FOR
THEIR INNER RAGE.
THEY CAN'T HANDLE THAT THEY WERE
EXPOSED.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> TO SHIP FAMILIES HERE,
CHILDREN HERE, ON A LIE, AND USE
THEM AS POLITICAL PAWNS IS A
TRULY INHUMANE THING TO DO.
>> WE WOKE UP TO THE NEWS THIS
MORNING THAT GOVERNOR RON
DeSANTIS OF FLORIDA SENT TWO
PLANE LOADS OF MIGRANTS TO
MARTHA'S VINEYARD OFF THE COAST
OF MASSACHUSETTS, KIDS AND WHAT
NOT.
AND I'M NOT SAYING, THIS IS NOT
A ONE FOR ONE, THIS IS NOT A
PARALLEL HERE IN ANY WAY, BUT IT
DOES ADDRESS SOME OF THE SAME
THEMES THAT ARE PART OF THIS
DOCUMENTARY.
>> IT'S THE AND STRACK SHUN OF
HUMAN LIFE.
>> I GET THEY'RE TRYING TO MAKE
A POINT BUT THESE ARE PEOPLE
YOU'RE PLAYING WITH.
THESE ARE REAL, LIVE PEOPLE WITH
CHILDREN AND OLDER PEOPLE AND,
YOU KNOW, WE CAN WORK IT OUT BUT
IF YOU'RE GOING TO BE A BONE
HEAD, WHO WANTS TO PLAY WITH
YOU.
>> Sean: JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN
FLYING ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS IN THE
DARK OF NIGHT TO EVERY STATE IN
THE COUNTRY.
ONE LOCAL STATE REP TWEETED
QUOTE REPUBLICANS HAVE CALLED
THEMSELVES CHRISTIANS HAVE BEEN
PLOTTING FOR SOME TIME TO YOOHOO
MAN LIVES AS POLITICAL PAWNS.
IT IS EVIL, IT IS INHUMANE.
WHO KNEW MARTHA'S VINEYARD WAS
SUCH AN INHUMANE PLACE TO BE.
MEANWHILE, CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR
GAVIN NEWSOME IS CALLING FOR THE
DOJ NOW TO ARREST GOVERNOR RON
DeSANTIS FOR KIDNAPPING.
GOVERNOR, I KNOW YOU'RE NOT
PARTICULARLY BRIGHT BUT IF YOU
WANT TO GO DOWN THIS ROAD WE'LL
PLAY AND YOUR SANCTUARY STATE IS
NOT ABIDING BY FEDERAL LAW.
JOE BIDEN AND HIS SANCTUARY
POLICIES BY THE U.S. IS NOT
ABIDING BY THE LAW OF THE LAND.
YOU'RE BOTH AIDING AND ABETTING
LAW BREAKING AND ARE INVOLVED IN
HUMAN TRAFFICKING SO MERRICK
GARLAND DID NOT WEAPONIZE THE
DOJ BOTH OF YOU WOULD PROBABLY
BE ARRESTED APPEAR BY THE WAY
WITH GOOD CAUSE.
KEEP IN MIND FOR MORE THAN A
YEAR THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
HAS BEEN FLYING THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF MIGRANTS ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY, YOU KNOW, THOSE
SECRET 2:00 A.M. FLIGHTS,
REGIONAL AIRPORTS IN THE DARK OF
NIGHT, DOZENS OF STATES.
THIS INCLUDES 70 LATE-NIGHT
FLIGHTS FROM THE BORDER TO
FLORIDA.
OH.
SO THAT INHUMANE TREATMENT
HAPPENED TO RON DeSANTIS IN HIS
STATE.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS NOW
CLEARLY ATTEMPTING TO QUIETLY
RESETTLE THE ROUGHLY THREE
MILLION, I REPEAT, THREE MILLION
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS WHO HAVE
POURED ACROSS OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER SINCE JOE BIDEN'S
INAUGURATION.
IN JULY ALONE NEARLY 200,000
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ENTERED
TEXAS, ARIZONA, CALIFORNIA
ILLEGALLY.
AND, REMEMBER, THESE ARE THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE APPREHENDED BY
BORDER PATROL.
SO WE HAVE NO IDEA HOW MANY MORE
MAY HAVE ENTERED THE COUNTRY
UNDETECTED.
BY THE WAY WE'RE ALSO GETTING
PEOPLE ON TERROR WATCH LISTS
THAT ARE BEING CAUGHT AND SOME
ARE GETTING BY.
THAT IS NOT GOOD FOR THE
COUNTRY'S SECURITY.
WHAT WE DO KNOW THAT WHILE THE
SPOILED LIBERAL VIRTUE SIGNALING
RESIDENTS OF MARTHA'S VINEYARD
ARE FREAKING OUT OVER 50 ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS, BORDER TOWNS AND
STATES ARE IN AN ACTUAL STATE OF
CRISIS.
THEY HAVE HAD TO DEAL WITH
MILLIONS OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS,
NOT 50.
AND TONIGHT THE CITY OF EL PASO
IS TOTALLY AND COMPLETELY
OVERWHELMED WITH AROUND A
THOUSAND ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS NOW
SLEEPING ON THE STREETS, NO
ACCESS TO TOILETS, SHOWERS,
CLEAN CLOTHES.
THE CITY'S CONGRESSMAN CALLED IT
A POCK LEADERSHIP PARTICULAR
ACCORDING TO THE LEFT.
WHAT YOU'LL SEE HERE IS TOTALLY
FINE BUT SENDING 50 MIGRANTS TO
MARTHA'S VINEYARD IS EVIL AND
INHUMANE AND WE CAN'T TAKE A FEW
OF THE 30 ACRES OF BARACK OBAMA
HAS AND TURN IT INTO A TENT
CITY?
NOW TONIGHT BILL MA LIEU ENGINE
IS REPORTING IN EL PASO JUST
APPROVED A $2 MILLION CONTRACT
TO BUS THESE MIGRANTS OUT OF
TOWNS FOR THE NEXT 16 MONTHS
INCLUDING TO NEW YORK CITY,
ANOTHER SANCTUARY CITY.
LET'S BE CLEAR.
WHEN THE DEMOCRATS OF EL PASO OR
GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT OR THE
GOVERNOR OF ARIZONA OR THE
GOVERNOR OF FLORIDA BUS MIGRANTS
TORQUES LET'S SAY, OH, THAT'S
RIGHT, KAMALA HARRIS'S DC
MANSION OR THE WHITE HOUSE OR
NEW YORK OR CHICAGO OR MARTHA'S
VINEYARD, THEY'RE TRYING TO DRAW
ATTENTION TO WHAT THEY HAVE HAD
TO DEAL WITH, AND THAT IS JOE
BIDEN'S POLICY OF NOT ENFORCING
THE LAW OF THE LAND, AIDING AND
ABETTING LAW BREAKING, AND
ACTUALLY GIVING PREFERENTIAL
TREATMENT TO ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
IT'S A DIRE CRISIS.
SOME PEOPLE ARE DYING BECAUSE
THEY ARE COMING HERE.
AND BY THE WAY, IT'S MADE WORSE
BY THE DEMOCRATS FAR AWAY FROM
THE BORDER, MORE THAN HAPPY
IGNORE AND LECTURE THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY.
IN FACT NOT ONLY IS THE WHITE
HOUSE REFUSING TO ADDRESS
BIDEN'S BORDER CRISIS, THEY'RE
NOT EVEN WILLING TO ADMIT
THERE'S A PROBLEM.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> DOES THE WHITE HOUSE STAND BY
THOSE COMMENTS THAT THE BORDER
IS SECURE?
>> WHAT WE STAND BY IS THAT WE
ARE DOING EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE FOLLOW THE
PROCESS THAT'S BEEN PUT FORTH.
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE HISTORIC
FUNDING TO DO JUST THAT, TO MAKE
SURE THAT, YOU KNOW, TO, TO MAKE
SURE THAT -- TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE FOLKS THAT WE ENCOUNTER AT
THE BORDER BE REMOVED OR
EXPELLED.
>> Sean: WELL, KARIN
JEANNE-PIERRE IS REALLY BAD AT
HER JOB, BUT THAT IS WHAT IT IS.
SHE KNOWS WHAT'S HAPPENING AT
THE BORDER AND SHE KNOWS IT
LOOKS REALLY BAD.
SHE ALSO KNOWS THAT HER BOSS,
JOE BIDEN'S NOT GOING TO DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT EXCEPT LIE TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE BECAUSE BOTH
JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS
DON'T CARE ABOUT SUFFERING ON
EITHER SIDE OF THE BORDER AND
JUST LAST WEEK KAMALA SAID OUR
BORDER IS SECURE AN OUTRIGHT
LIE.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THE HUMAN
SMUGGLING, THE DRUG SMUGGLING,
THE FENTANYL OR OPIOID CRISIS
AND ACCORDING TO THEM SECURING
THE BORDER AND FINISHING THE
WALL IS RACIST.
SO HERE WE ARE WIT